the beautiful thing though about where
we are right now and one of the reasons
i feel okay
moving out of la and you're out of la is
that
we can we're in control of our own
business now we don't necessarily need
them
and i don't know a whole lot of people
who are comics who are making their
money
because they live in los angeles no
right like not at all we're good we're
good i mean we're at a good stage to be
a stand-up because
when we were coming up in the late 90s
you were at the mercy of network execs
yeah somebody's saying
uh we're gonna allow your material to be
seen
now because we all knew those funny guys
in l.a that just couldn't sell tickets
or couldn't get on the road like that
because they didn't nobody was
[ __ ] with them really now with
youtube you kind of
control your own narrative it's up to
you yeah really is what is
early on like i remember early on i did
whatever i had to do to make a little
extra
like uh i was on univision joey
diaz called me one week and he was like
hey dog univision they're looking for
comics he goes can you pretend to be
half hispanic
is that k lokos yeah and i go yeah i go
yeah i can be half hispanic and he goes
all right
you need to write five minutes of
material about being half jewish half
cuban let's see
so i went down they didn't check me or
anything so i did five minutes about
being half jewish half cuban
and they were like you were great can
you come back and do five more minutes
i'm like i don't think so
it's all the latin material i got but i
would do anything
to get i went on the gong sh the the new
god i remember going on the new gong
show
and they said do you want to do your
material and i didn't want to do my
actual material and get gonged
so i pretended to be a character named
uh
david paragamo who was a combination of
two open micros that i started with joe
paragamo and david wright
and i would start i would do one-liners
but i would do david's setup and joe's
punch lines
and so i got gong in like 20 seconds but
i was i was creating
yeah so so i was creating characters
just to get
you're also streaming you also stripped
in college i also stripped in college
but did you
know that did you yeah a couple times
did you do anything
like whatever it takes you kind of stuff
when you were coming up at all
you know i was in the military oh i
didn't know that so i was
in the navy i was on tv and active duty
david
when i was on bet common view i took a
week's leave
drove up to la because they filmed the
whole season in a week that's why my dad
loves you my dad was in the navy
oh really yeah a good man that was uh
you know we take
we take it was three or five episodes
they would
be t would take three or five episodes a
day monday through friday so the whole
season got filmed in a week
and so i just took a week's leave and
back then it was a contest
i kept winning my rounds and then they
said okay you
now you're gonna get an hour special so
i came back like a month
later filmed my hour special and keep in
mind i probably had 20 minutes
it was the slowest hour because i'd be
like i was
walking the stage like yeah
yeah when i say i waited till the last
laptop it was silence and i get the next
joke
it was i just remember that clock is
right in front of you and i never
go how [ __ ] long is 60 minutes who
else was it
were in those competitions anybody we
would recognize that you competed
against uh
that year um i don't know i'll tell you
this i don't know
who i competed against but when i became
the host the next year
that uh if mike epps was on
d-ray was on joe coy was on
um i want to say cat was on but i
i'm not positive but that that
that's the thing about bet they got a
little [ __ ] library of legends
just sitting there yeah they're not on
youtube they're not on bet they're just
sitting there
have you guys seen this photo of adult
yeah yeah so this photo is going viral
and a lot of people had a lot of
different feelings
about it a lot of people came out and
said that they were offended that she
was cultural
appropriating jamaican culture and then
a bunch of people who were jamaican came
out
and basically said shut up unless you're
jamaican she's at the notting hill
festival this is just what they do to
celebrate that culture
and adele's doing nothing wrong a couple
days later
your favorite person ever chet hanks
came out and posted this video
shooting a boy shooting his shot with
adele yes
adele adele adele
you know i sent me a priya from a long
time but after me see a pixel a day
it's sweden i'm gonna tell no lie my
girl
dear style fit yo be god yourself
the look away first of all it's tough
being tom hanks son let's just yeah man
it's also tough your dad's force gump
it's a tough go but that doesn't mean
you have to wear jean shorts with white
socks pulled up like there's no excuse
for that
you know what i mean like i don't know i
don't care whose son you are
jean shorts with your white socks pulled
up that's it's not your look it's a
tough
[ __ ] goal he's entertaining to me he
dude he's
super entertaining yeah there's no doubt
that jamaica
he's a white rapper yeah oh he's a
rapper i do you have a problem
with what adele was wearing i don't yeah
i don't either right
no i mean it's it's no different than uh
you see people wearing the
the british flag or the american flag
yeah man
trust me there's worse things to be mad
about yeah this ain't it
don't don't put point your negativity i
would be more mad at the jeans and the
white sox than i would be at the bikini
i think i think
but but this dude man i love his a
hundred percent confidence and
commitment
100 percent to to this like he's
do what do you think what happened right
that's why he took his shot she's single
now she lost all that weight and ditched
homeboy what
uh what kind of game you think chet
hanks has
if adele calls chet hanks i bet he's
pretty smooth criminal again when your
dad's tom hanks
you're gonna have some chops you want me
my dad
here put this on i got the the bottom
half of splash
come on what do we have to do you want
to be my dad too that's all i've been
saying yeah i'll be my dad
i'd have a shirt my white shirt would be
like my dad's thomas yeah yeah
we'll read the script of course hey i'm
tom hanks's son
yeah i would tell you if i was in high
school like prom homecoming
you want to come to my house yeah you
know before we tape before we go to the
dance let's go to my house meet my dad
i was like yeah good for him yeah i
think i love when he does that jamaican
voice
it's [ __ ] good it is good
is it a jamaican voice okay i mean yeah
it's pretty
the look away that was little much yeah
the whole thing is a little awkward
which is why i enjoy it yeah that's why
i enjoy it
yeah well you wait for him to break
character he never breaks it never
taiwan it's kind of a kite festival
and then i did you see this i saw this
this is
so insane yeah a little girl got caught
up no
yep what the end of the night
she's like says three years old let me
play the part where she gets caught up
keep watching this look at this
keep watching look how high this [ __ ]
gets
oh my gosh
and she's holding on she is i think
she's wrapped like it just caught her
is there someone staring the cat at this
point yeah someone has it on this side
pull down
i mean because it's in the tail of it
they have the the front of it
oh my god and then finally boom they
caught her
holy [ __ ] did you see how high that
thing got yeah
that is just insane that is crazy oh my
gosh
that is insane i can't um
i don't know also as a parent how my
brain computes that if i was sitting
there watching that
there's no no there's no there's no way
to even compute like
how where your mind goes on that i
i would have no idea i would have tried
to do the follow it around and it is
weird yeah 100
yeah like like catching up dude yeah
exactly like the highest pun of all time
but uh it is like i was on a lake balboa
with my family my son wanted to go on
those swan boats yeah
and we go to the middle of the lake i'm
the only one pedaling and that's a good
leg looks like a [ __ ]
i was bike riding earlier that day and
i'm like oh if we get stuck out or
something like that
and then my son's like flipping out but
then your mind starts thinking i'm like
worst case scenario if we got stuck this
we have left vests on so
it's very weird as a parent you go
through worst case
and like this is what i'll do here
that's what i'll do here where are you
with by the way do you and your girl you
you public display of attention people
i'm not no i'm not i mean i'll i'll grab
some hands hands
and like yesterday your mom's around
like her mom turned out like to do
something like grab her titties
to meet them in front of her mom no her
mom would turn her oh okay yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i i'm never
been a makeout
like no oh god the makeout people you
know when someone's in the line in front
of you and
you can hear like that oh and you're
like
14 yes first of all
not for me dude no you don't have i
don't want to have a boner around a
bunch of other people
no know i'm for sure going to get one if
we start kissing because then my brain
goes it's go time
yeah what but my wife will always say my
genes can't control
you you can't fit well you can't fit in
here yeah you see everything
my my wife when she says she's like i
start making out with her
like at the house and then i start to
get into it but you know booty and boobs
and she's like no no can't we just make
out i'm like
no that's not oh no why why and she's
like this is just fun just to kind of
and then think about what might happen
later
no no no no no no this is it's time it's
go time my guy goes it's go time yeah
you don't do it we're gonna prom well
she says she's like why can't we just
kind of tease each other and then come
back to it later i'm like oh no
that sounds terrible talking about blue
balls yeah that doesn't let's go to the
strip club
yeah i'm sorry i'm at cheetahs that's
why i don't go to school
because i'll get singles out what the
reason i hated strip clubs and i never
quite got it was
never went to the boom boom room but i
don't want to have to
pay you because i can touch my dick for
free
yeah do you know what i mean like when i
used to go with a bunch of people and it
was drinks
and every it was like a fun group even
then but that would make at least sense
to me somebody's bachelor party
but go into the boom boom room i gotta
buy you what a 400
bottle of what they'll hustle you they
do that dude they're the best they are
the ultimate hustlers because once
you're like look i don't want and then
that knee hits your dick
like one bottle yeah yeah just take my
credit card yeah
what happened to our friend dude he just
came to his dad's platinum credit card